in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Scott
and Asia are with us hey guys how are
you good thank you for having us
welcome welcome did I pronounce your
name right hey sure yeah okay perfect
make sure I didn't mess that up where
you guys from Northern California the
town Colfax California it's a little bit
outside of Sacramento okay cool
nice area fun well good to have you guys
welcome to Nashville you're here to do
your debt-free scream up yes we are
I love it I love it how much have you
paid off we paid off seventy three
thousand dollars
mmm good and how long did that take 24
months Wow fast and your range of income
during that time we started at about 80
mm-hmm and we finished at about a
hundred and fifty four thousand okay so
in two years you doubled your income how
did you do that well I was not quite a
stay-at-home mom I probably worked about
eight hours a month and then when we
decided to do this you went you went
all-in huh yeah oh yeah okay so what do
you do
we're both nurses oh okay very cool good
yeah that's a quick income you can jump
in and out of that and long as you keep
your certifications and everything and
there's always a need right yeah so one
of us was literally always at work yeah
I bet so one of us worked in one of us
stayed home and took took care of the
kids a lot of hours a lot of hours a lot
of overtime whenever it came up as well
I mean you kicked butt and 24 months you
did 73 grand that's just rockin thank
you I mean that's that's thinking it's
almost $3,000 a month average yeah it
was tough it was a lot over time and the
only time he came up we were there just
smacked it well well done so what kind
of debt was the 73,000 student loans
although it was the majority of we also
had a truck loan that was about 22 of it
and we had some dental bills okay that
was a couple thousand as well so you're
just kind of normal
yeah how long have you guys been married
five years five years shattered a that
just passed oh happy anniversary yeah
thank you so three years into your
5-year marriage you said alright
something's gotta give
what cause
that what was the because the switch to
flip we have well we have two kids and
so it was our first child our son and
two years ago we were just finding out
that he is autistic and so when you hear
something like that you're not no one's
prepared for it but it also made us
think about his future is are we gonna
have to take care of him forever till we
die and then have to have money left
over for someone to take care of him
after after we die so I mean we were
making it we weren't you know living
lavishly but you know it was we were
doing okay and then so we just we
thought we really need to clean up our
lives so we can help and prepare and
have things ready because we weren't
prepared for what we might need or what
what it might take to to have him
progress and move on yeah it is you know
some different therapies and things that
are available you got to be able to fund
all of that and like you said take care
of him if something happened to you
house god forbid so well very cool well
there's nothing like a wake-up call I
mean thank you yes and ding ding right
there and so what did you do once you
decided this well we so I I had paid my
mom and I had helped pay for a financial
peace class for my middle brother years
ago and then I I didn't give it any
other thought I was in school and then I
remember I was like you know I did this
thing for my brother let me check it out
and so we looked at it and he actually
had been listening to your radio show oh
cool and so we downloaded the Total
Money Makeover and we started it mm-hmm
and we had our first when we had our
first budget meeting you can yeah our
first budget meeting that was the most
you know that was one of the most
tougher ones because we were sitting
there trying to figure this all out and
I can just remember her saying you know
because it was it's tough to go through
all this thing you know you're getting
upset you're trying to do it because
you're looking at all for real and you
say you know she was getting upset this
is supposed to be fun who told you it
was gonna be
nothing fun about it the first budget
meeting is a complete fight subsequent
meetings much better yeah last one I
mean you know we still have them every
month but the last was fun yes yes ding
knock it out you're done and yeah it's
that fun of ringing the bell yes yeah
very well done good for you guys that's
cool
so the Sacramento radio station what
you're listening to or is it yes okay
cool that's a great radio station that
we're on there they do a good job
all right well really cool you guys very
very fun I love it
matter of fact rachel is going to be in
Sacramento Tuesday or Wednesday of Nick
a week from my goodness two weeks from
now something like that the end of the
book tour it's towards the end of the
book tour yeah very cool well you guys
congratulations very well done how does
it feel feels amazing yeah it's not to
sound cliche but it is life-changing it
really is and like the month after we
were done with our debt we took this
whole summer I took most of the summer
off from working and we jam-packed our
life with all kinds of kid adventures
good we went to Legoland and you only
visits and all the stuff that we put off
mm-hmm during that 24 months you do
nothing but work no yes that's true I
mean you work like no one else now you
can work like no one else you know
that's very good
good very cool so when people find out
you paid off that what do you tell them
the secret is for paying off seventy
three thousand dollars and twenty four
months oh my gosh someone really asked
me like what's the secret and I looked
at her and I was like there's no secret
you don't have and you you listen to
Dave Ramsey
there you go that's what you know now
sir I mean really that's the truth we
tell them you gotta have they gotta
listen to you and you watch these Duffy
screams on YouTube that is a department
or listen to it and every time every
time I hear someone scream I think oh my
gosh it is it's real it can really
happen it can really happen and then one
day it really happened and now you're
standing here in my lobby
I feel surreal but we're pretty neat
that's pretty neat yeah we do a lot of
we do a lot of corny surreal cliche
things around here we believe in them
they're big that's cool good for you
guys I'm so proud of you thank you so
much so doing the written budget and
working your butt off so when it comes
down to this you guys want to work like
crazy people
yes staying motivated you know motivated
I attended one of your smart money yeah
conferences we know we're out in Rocklin
there was a giant Church in Sacramento
area and so I took my youngest brother
and you know to help give him some
motivation cool it was you know and then
we listened to your radio show
constantly and I don't want to like talk
to everybody about you all the time
yeah I don't do that that's weird but we
do have some friends that are there on
their own journey and they're starting
so oh cool well good for them very cool
well we're so proud of you guys way to
go very well done you took control of
your lives man you changed your family
tree very well done
all right we are going to give you a
copy of Kris Hogan's retire inspired
book number one best-selling book
because that's the next chapter building
wealth and the reason to get out of debt
is not just to be rid of the debt but
it's also because now you got your
income and now you can do anything and
you can build wealth and increase your
generosity and be prepared for the the
things you faced with this youngster and
you'll be ready your gates game own way
did that way to go very well done all
right Scott and Asia from Sacramento
California area $73,000 paid off in 24
months make an eighty but with ot baby
up to 154 count it down let's hear a
debt free scream three two one we're
free
man you got this you can do it you can
do it you keep hearing these people do
these debt-free screams on this show and
you wonder if it's real well it's real
you can't make this crap up you can't
make this stuff up people's lives are
too real I mean that lady went back to
work and really kicked the hours in and
now she doesn't have to really that's
how you do it I mean there's a great
place to go when you're broke to work
and they cleaned up their mess two years
of their whole life they spent very
intensely so now they have their whole
life to live free and in control and
what that does for your marriage it is
life changing that's not cliche it is
life changing so what are you gonna
change your life I'm talking to you yeah
you this is the Dave Ramsey show hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
you can do this you know that really is
a message whether you've got two hundred
seventy thousand dollars in student loan
debt or twenty seven thousand well
you've got a fifty thousand dollar
income on a $500,000 in common